well it is friday night that means high
school football back in action tonight
across the valley including at shadow
ridge high school friday night lights
that's where we find 8 sports kevin
martin joining us live ahead of the
raiders friday night showcase game kevin
take it away
well hey brian thank you very much we
have an intriguing match-up on hand
shadow ridge hosting durango high school
as you mentioned in the raiders showcase
game of the night and i'm joined by
former raider super bowl champ keith
moody thank you so much and we were just
talking off air that you grew up in
syracuse you played high school ball in
syracuse got dr you played it a lot of
cold weather this is not normal high
school weather for you absolutely not no
i'm used to it being about 30 degrees
and some rain and maybe even a little
snow so coming out here and it's 100
degrees when they start kickoff it's
quite an adjustment for for me thinking
about high school football and you know
you've obviously played at every level
nothing like friday night lights right
absolutely not this is great for the
kids to have the fans here the community
here and the raider organization is
committed to the community
owner mark davis and all of the raider
organization love to be involved in the
community that's why the alumni are at
so many of these community functions and
i mentioned super bowl champ you
actually have your super bowl ring on if
you can show the camera that's awesome
you know still talk about what the pride
is wearing that every single day well
it's a it's a dream come true i mean i
grew up in a little area in syracuse and
to think that one day i would have a
super bowl ring being part of the
raiders and that was tom flory's first
year as a head coach and he won the
super bowl as a head coach so we're all
very proud of him going into the hall of
fame and looking forward to it
celebration soon
for him well thank you so much keith
have fun tonight stay cool and of course
coming up at 11 we'll have highlights of
shadow ridge and durango high school
reporting live at shadow ridge high
school kevin martin 8 sports now